Hi, I'm Dr. Lillian Glass.
As a body language expert, a lot of people ask me, "What do I do with my hands?"
"What do I do when I talk?"
And I tell them, first of all, it depends on your culture.
Because in certain cultures, using the hands is a very acceptable thing.
But in other cultures, it may not be.
But use of the hands is a good thing.
Don't try to clasp your hands together because sometimes if you do that,...
...you won't be able to express yourself fully.
So you need to express yourself using your hands.
Let yourself out.
But make sure your gestures are not excessive.
Make sure they match what you're saying.
For example, if you are talking about something big,...
...you want to show that with your hand movement.
If you are talking about something small, you want to show that with your hand movement.
So again use your hands for emphasis, and that way, it will make sense.
This has been Dr. Lillian Glass with Mahalo.com.
And if you'd like more information about body language and communication skills,...
...go to my website, www.drlillianglass.com.
And if you'd like to see more videos, they're right here.